next thing you know I looked down and I
had a hundred thousand followers it is
something that transformed the
trajectory of my life it's a matter of
finding what lights you up and what you
actually love and infusing that into the
content so making sure in the first two
seconds of that video I'm showing a
problem and quickly how I solve it and
then I get into the video
so how do you effortlessly create short
form content that people love to watch
I'm excited because in today's episode
of the think media podcast I'm getting
to sit down with Kat Norton aka Miss
Excel who has created an incredible
brand helping people learn Microsoft
Excel but is also sharing that content
on the internet serving people and not
only are we going to talk about video
and short form content but also how to
kind of position yourself and package
what you know and really make an impact
B2B and even B to C so cat welcome to
the show thank you so much I'm so
excited to be here I'm so grateful uh
that we're hanging out in San Diego
social media marketing world you spoke
yesterday and you crushed your session
all about short form video and so give
me a high level why do you love short
form video so short form video is
something super near and dear to my
heart because it is something that
transformed the trajectory of my life so
before short form video content and
creating it I did not have a business
and it is essentially what what my
business was built on Wow and so people
I love the word effortlessly in your
title and when it comes to creating
content it can feel overwhelming so how
can people get started without the
overwhelm so it really comes down to
basically figuring out how you get into
a creative Flow State and that's a big
part of it to make those ideas drop in
of what you actually want to go in and
create so that's something that I like
to talk about a lot in terms of what are
ways that we can kind of biohack our own
minds and figure out how to get from a
left brain-dominated state where we're
more analytical and thinking about the
future in the past into more of the
right side of the Mind where we're
getting those creative downloads and
it's really just about finding
activities within yourself that shift
you into that right side of the mind so
take us into your process how do you
biohack yourself into that creative Flow
State yeah so for me it really looks
like getting out in nature I live out in
Sedona and the Red Rocks so for me it's
getting outside grounding myself I do
yoga I meditate Tate things like that
and really just staying out of left
brained activities too so when I wake up
on my creative days I'm not like
checking my emails or doing anything
where I would be analyzing and I focus
more on like creative Flow State
activities I got it and and then are you
capturing ideas like if you're
meditating do you have a journal and
you're like oh that's one so how are you
what are you capturing what are you
writing down yeah so typically when I'm
getting into the flow seat I will have
like a notebook near me in case any
ideas drop in but then once I'm in that
state is when I go through and I start
scrolling on social media first taking a
look at Trends seeing what's going on
and seeing what ideas start clicking
like I'll see like Drop It Like It's Hot
by Snoop Dogg trending I'm like okay I
can match that with the drop down menu
right like all these things start to
click once I'm scrolling and looking
around on social from that creative Flow
State that's when some ideas start
dropping in and then I look at how can I
up level those Trends how can I make
those authentic to me how can I go in
and add that creative Spin and that's
really where the creative process Flows
In in and so give us oh take a step back
I introduced you as Miss Excel but pitch
what you do so we can think about how
you're applying something that could
seem
boring yeah could seem just super like
that's Excel and yet you're pulling
create a flow State into that so
describe what you do and what you teach
so I pick Microsoft Excel fun that's
really the underline of what I do and
it's really expanded out into the other
Microsoft Office product but essentially
I take things that would traditionally
be boring and dry but are things that
people need to know at work quite often
and then Infuse them with fun and
creativity so that it's actually
something entertaining and you're
actually paying attention so then you
learn the skills and that's really what
I went through too when building my
courses and how can I Infuse the courses
with as much creativity too got it so
you're taking something because if
someone's listening to this they might
think how is originating alone or
describing different loan products to a
home buyer or home seller gonna be fun
yeah how do I take my business and
actually make it fun or creative so you
take whatever it is that you have but
your goal is to then actually bring in
Trendy music bring in some kind of idea
that's sort of make the extemporane you
pull it into the the here and now and so
you're getting into a flow State you're
jotting down ideas you're also jumping
on social media looking at Trends and
what are some tips for someone that says
I I just can't create that bridge I see
that okay someone's dancing over here
and I see this this sound and I'm not
and but like how does that apply to like
my service provider business so first
off I would say if you don't like
dancing don't dance that's always the
advice I give people because I feel like
a lot of times on social media people
are encouraged to dance and do the
trends but for me when creating my
business I was just pulling in things
that are authentic to me I was like what
do I want to do with my life what do I
love and I was like I love to help
people I love Excel and I love today and
how can I put those three things that I
love in a video so for me the dancing
was just something authentic to me but
really it's a matter of finding what
lights you up and what you actually love
and infusing that into the content and
then just from a creative perspective
it's really going in and one technique a
lot of people use is storytelling with
that and that's just the way to kind of
build a narrative around what you're
trying to teach that's a way to make it
entertaining without necessarily having
to dance on the screen that's amazing
and can you think of any vertical videos
you've done that have been your highest
performing videos and how those came
together like what was was it a trending
audio and what are some lessons that
maybe some of your breakout videos
taught you yeah so really it comes down
to these four things the first thing is
that the video had an element of
polarity to it and by polarity it kind
of hit it in a couple ways it was one
the nature of the content itself I was
combining two things that people would
normally never combine like Excel and
dancing and that sparked that
conversation that got people who you
know might not even be interested in
Excel they're like what is this girl
doing you know and that really is what
got my videos off the ground and then
the video that I'm envisioning in
particular also had an additional layer
of polarity to it it's where I showed
how to do an Excel tip in one way where
there were like four other options so
instead of being like here are the four
ways you can break text out of your cell
it was I showed one way and by just
showing one it actually created
conversation around it because people
are like what choose flashville and not
the checks The Columns tool you know and
that also created conversation a second
thing is the storytelling element so I
typically will jump into actual
characters especially if I want to
underlay trending music and do things
without speaking I'll just dress as
different characters label myself on the
screen and kind of create this narrative
around the content so that way even if
someone has seen that Excel tip before
they still might be commenting and
relating to it because they're like oh
like this has happened with my boss
before things like that third thing is
problem solving so making sure in the
first two seconds of that video I'm
showing a problem and quickly how I
solve it and then I get into the video
because that's usually my hook for
getting someone in especially in the
Excel space it's like how is this going
to save me time how is this going to
make me more efficient and then the
fourth thing really is just going in and
having that authentic energy so people
people can tell on a subconscious subtle
level if you are uncomfortable on screen
so I will go through multiple times and
make sure that how I feel on the inside
is what is showing up on the outside on
the other side of that screen because
that's what really builds that trust
with your audience right if someone's
looking a little Shifty on screen you
know like you might be like oh I want to
buy their stuff you know so I spend a
lot of time cultivating the energy
within me so that when I come up on
screen it's like bam you know someone
wants to enter the virtual world you
have created on the other side of that
screen this video is brought to you by
stream yard stream yard is our go-to
platform for streaming to YouTube and
Facebook with an incredibly easy to use
interface for built-in branding
transitions text lower thirds and
seamlessly bringing on guests it really
is one of the best options when it comes
to live streaming and what's so cool is
they've implemented a brand new feature
called local recording take control of
your audio and video with local
recordings by separating out your audio
and video from your guests this feature
gives you the control over your content
for later use making it perfect for
podcasts and video creators just go to
streamwoodthink.com to get started now
and give me an example of a character
when you say characters what do you mean
so typically
I like more of office
characters so I'll be a boss in one
section then I'll be a co-worker then
I'll like be me you know jumping in the
video like saving the day with the exult
him and really just kind of creating
that office narrative because that's
typically where my products are used
that's amazing and let's talk a little
bit about how you became Miss Excel
people want to know how they found their
Niche it's super strong at first it
doesn't appear pure very strong or it
just appears like that seems average but
you have impacted over a million people
that have been a part of your programs
and you have just all this influence and
as you Niche down in something I mean
millions and millions and you probably
know the number how many people use
Microsoft Office Products it's
outrageous and so it's it is a powerful
Niche it's specific within the niche
you're able to broaden a little bit more
now but I know people watching this I
mean they feel like the world's
saturated they feel like you know how do
I pick my thing and maybe two there
could be something present in their
expertise or their experience but
they're devaluing because it just seems
like it's old Excel or something so what
was the Journey of becoming Miss Excel
and finding your thing finding your
Niche yeah I mean for me it was really
all a mindset game so it started off I
was a consultant at a business before
this doing securitization reviews for
banks and every week I was traveling to
a different state in the U.S and also I
was teaching Microsoft Excel on the side
internally at my day job just because I
liked it and then with the start of the
pandemic I found myself back in my
childhood bedroom of my parents house
being like I don't know what I want to
do with my life but this ain't it and I
was 27 years old just trying to figure
it out and I really went inward I was
like okay what do I want to do with my
time on this planet what actually lights
me up and in going inward I was like
okay I see you know I have these
limiting beliefs going on about myself
I've had a pretty severe anxiety
disorder I hated having attention on me
not something you would really want for
going on Tick Tock so I spent the first
couple months just really working on
myself and clearing a lot of that out
day in day night just you know reading
learning about the Mind learning how I
can rewire that then I got to this place
where I'll never forget this it was
April of 2020 I didn't start my business
till June I came out of my childhood
bedroom and I was like Mom I'm going to
be rich and famous soon so I need you to
prepare your nervous system for that
she's just like Catholic or clean your
room he thought she's like what but just
every cell in my body knew something
massive was about to happen so then I'm
on the phone fast forward to June with
one of my best friends and she's like
but if you put the Excel tips on Tick
Tock and I was like 27 with the
corporate job I can't just make Tick
Tock but in that moment when she said it
I also saw it I saw you know that Drake
song Tuesday side left right foot slide
I saw myself dancing to the juicy slide
to the left and the right function in
Excel above my head and at this point
I'm like I don't know how to video edit
I don't know how one would get an Excel
screen above their head right but I
could not shake this idea so next two
days go by my brain is like you can't ah
make a tick tock but my gut was like
make the tick tock and I'll never forget
my schedule clears on a Friday afternoon
I'm like you know what I'm just gonna
make a test video and see if this works
and I did it and was like oh this is
actually pretty cool so I whip out 10
more videos and make my secret Tech Talk
account Miss Excel and I only told my
mother and my boyfriend what I was doing
and I started silently posting one video
a day and then by the fourth video it
reaches a hundred thousand views and I'm
like since all these people I know
people at work I'm like oh my gosh and
then by the sixth video the CEO of an
I.T company reaches out and it's like
hey I love your teaching style I'm
looking to create G Suite training
videos for students parents and teachers
because this one all the schools were
starting to go digital so at this point
I'm like well clearly I'm a Microsoft
gal but you know I could figure this out
so I formed an LLC got a green screen a
ring light I moved my childhood bedroom
furniture into a corner and made a
little studio in my room and was working
my day job during the day cranking out
videos selling them back to the sky at
night and at the same time I kept making
the most Excel context at this point I'm
like you know what it's an opportunity
magnet you know it's helping a lot of
people out there I'll just keep doing
this so about three weeks go by and I
had my first video go viral on Tick Tock
and next thing know within a couple days
I looked down and I had a hundred
thousand followers and was like well now
what do I do right so I made an
Instagram as well and I kind of just
kept going viral across the platforms
each month into it it grew to a few
hundred thousand people across the
platforms and at that point I had no
product so come in November of 2020 I
was like dang I should probably have a
course or something going on so I made
my first Excel course in peace with so
much fun and creativity because after my
content if you've seen it like your girl
cannot have a boring course and so I
started selling Black Friday of 2020 and
then by January my courses were bringing
in more passive income each month than
my day job was so at that point I was
like kind of rethink my priorities out
here you know send it 40 hours a week at
the day job 10 hours a week on this and
it's doing the same so I couldn't see
everyone's a better judgment I quit my
day job and went full time on social
media and then over the next you know
few months I built out 10 more courses
and then that's how I scaled it into a
multi-million dollar business that's in
incredible what a story and so your
growth was really one year about it was
one year from starting while you had a
day job to being able to you made your
first course later that year and then
basically by the 2021 you were full-time
yes and then you started to scale and so
what is your advice as we land the plane
for productizing what you know online
courses has been the thing for you and
the majority of your impact is b2c so a
lot of people that just want to learn
Excel go deeper but also even B2B now
you know you can license your courses
and depending on how many people in the
business are learning what are some of
your advice for somebody that wants to
package what they know that you've
learned about when it comes to creating
online courses really core sales is
where it's at and really making sure you
create a course too one that's something
you love but two around the lifestyle
you want to create like I particularly
chose ever bring courses because I was
just looking for ways to stop trading
time for money I was like I jumped out
of my corporate job because I wanted to
just go out and live my life I wanted to
travel I wanted to do things you know
and so I made sure that I built this
this business around what lifestyle I
wanted to live like I was like I don't
want to be working you know 40 hour
weeks anymore I want to work 15 hour
weeks so I'm going to build a team build
a structure and build this out in a way
that will support that so that's a
really big thing too like versus
committing to doing like in person or
live things like unless it's something
that really lights you up definitely
like think on how you actually want to
get that modality out or really when it
comes to course creation I got the
process down pretty solid I was so this
is one thing that like really just gets
the higher going is selling the courses
before they are done and I started
selling a bundle of H courses where only
two were live so I had that fire under
me to whip out the other six so I got it
down to a process where I could build an
100 video training course in a week from
start to finish spend one day mapping it
out two days filming so two six hour
filming days a 12 hour course and then I
would spend three days video editing all
the videos and then on that seventh day
I would post the course and I was like
rinse and repeat got the process down
really well and that's what I did to
build out those first set that's amazing
and what are the titles of the courses a
few of them yeah so my main course is
Excel but then we also teach word
PowerPoint Outlook OneNote I have a
Google Sheets course a kids course now
yeah that's amazing and where do you
host them thinkific nice and so uh what
would your advice be a lot of people
hear your story it's so inspiring you
we're in a corporate job and now you've
created Freedom you're able to impact
people you're able to have fun leverage
social media create autonomy and be able
to travel I mean it's the dream it's why
a lot of people listen to the think
media podcast they're trying to achieve
some of those own things and their
unique Niche and their Unix unique
situation what's your advice be for
someone who's looking at the uphill
battle of starting from scratch the
competition that's out there you know
feeling the algorithm is against them
what is your advice to somebody that
wants to start right now this year take
messy action it's really once we come to
the terms that we are the only thing
really standing in our own way and once
we get out of our own way and release
any perfectionism release any attachment
to the outcome that's really where the
opportunities flow in my entire business
this has been inbound leads from I've
been in 50 different Global media
Outlets I've never reached out for press
all my corporate deals that have come
through have all just been through kind
of releasing that attachment to the
outcome and releasing The Narrative that
like this has to be hard like I went
into this I was like I'm just coming
here to have a good time I'm just gonna
have some fun on social media and see
what happens without having that
attachment to oh I need this to work or
I need this you know because then that
kind of like tunnel Visions ourselves
when we're like I'm gonna have to sell
this many courses to do this right most
of the way that my business grew were
ways that my conscious mind could have
not even thought up right like what I
thought of on day six on Tick Tock the
CEO of an I.T company is going to reach
out give me a side hustle to supplement
my income boom like no you know so
that's really where I kind of just left
it super open I was like I'm gonna go
out there and have some fun and I just
took messy action nothing was over
prepared nothing was overdone if I get
an idea I just go do it and you know
like I'm just having fun and
experimenting man I love it Miss Excel
IF people want to connect with you how
can they uh connect with you of course
link it up in the show notes yeah so I'm
miss.excel on Tick Tock and on Instagram
I'm also cat Norton on LinkedIn and the
Miss Excel on Twitter cat appreciate you
think media podcast thank you so much